hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video weg zum titel wahrscheinlich schon
eingeblendet whatsapp rang ich werde
jetzt heute keinen neuen whatsapp rang
machen da kommt ein neuer vielleicht in
ein paar tagen allerdings wollte ich
über zwei sachen reden
die gerade heute so passiert sind zwar
eine sache davon etwas mit dem mord zu
tun und die andere sache mit leuten von
meiner haustür im rtl also wird das
video jetzt quasi wieder so ein bisschen
trocken story team alles ein bisschen
verpacken ich hoffe dass es nicht allzu
lang wird habe wir fangen erst mal mit
dem ersten thema und der fokus meiner
kamera spinnt wiederum ein paar sekunden
später los oder also ich weiß nicht ob
es aussieht steht quasi direkt hier da
ist eine softbox und wenn ich irgendwie
so mache seht ihr so schatten immer im
gesicht aber ich glaube das ist besser
als in der fokussierung spendete erstmal
zu dem was wir schon einen titel
eingeblendet und zwar irgendwas mit
roxette prank wahrscheinlich ich bin
eigentlich nie in den trainings
unterwegs weil ich finde dass die trends
auf youtube in letzter zeit komplett
beschissen geworden sind also mir wurden
letztens auf platz eins videos angezeigt
von den chinesischen lkw fahrern die
rückwärts eingepackt haben
danke dafür youtube ist auf jeden fall
korrekt dass so was in den deutschen
trend dass ich setze mich da bin
eigentlich nicht weit auseinander
sondern produzieren konnten und lass
meine videos halbhoch allerdings hat
mein manager bei studio 71 mir heute
morgen so ein bild geschenkt und hatte
die nachricht erst gar nicht beachtet
beifahrer unterwegs war und ich will
erhalten ich irgend welche bilder
herunterladen weil ich nicht jetzt
unendlich datenvolumen habe und dann hat
er noch eine nachricht geschrieben wurde
an das bild weise geschrieben hat und
hat geschrieben einfach luca in den
spanischen trends und dazu dann dieses
bild ich bin also in den spanischen
youtube trends er mir dann nochmal
genaueren screenshot von dem video
geschickt und er sieht quasi so aus also
das video heißt romani wenige weess een
accord
zune video sehen als deponie caliente
troll epicor und dann halte ich auf dem
sambel
warum der youtuber der das hochgeladen
hat heißt youtuber world und sein video
hat über 18 millionen aufrufe nach zwei
tagen der reihe und damit einfach ich
auch informell drauf so entnimmt mich
einfach packt ihr schlagschatten hinter
den rücken macht den hintergrund
irgendwie blau bist du bescheuert
youtube will alter er setzt sich
dasselbe aufnahme mir das video jetzt
mal hier an und wundert euch nicht ich
mache hier keine einblendungen von den
videos oder so weil da könnt ihr mich
direkt wächst reifen also ich könnte ihn
auch wächst reiten weil er mich im namen
der benutzer so ich könnte es direkt
runter nehmen lassen aber ich bin da
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht auf krawall
gebürstet also ich meine mich jetzt auf
dem teller hat oder nichts mehr ist auch
scheißegal wenn er einfach mal ein video
genommen hätte kopiert hat und das bei
sich einfach hochgeladen hätte dann wäre
scheiße gewesen aber das jetzt
eigentlich habe ich will das video
trotzdem gern sehen
okay okay das ist jetzt nicht wahr so
sieht das quasi aus der youtuber hat 170
tausend abonnenten mit dem video
allerdings weil wir nun auf rufe jetzt
nach zwei tagen und einfach 37.000 likes
gegen 6000 des likes aber er schaltet
einfach mal so zehn millionen mal
werbung auf den zehn minuten video
meinte ich selber schalte ja auch
werbung und wenn ein video über zehn
minuten geht
habt ihr vielleicht selber schon
mitbekommen kann man bei youtube noch
eine zweite werbung schalten wir das
video hat enorm lang geht es natürlich
so ein bisschen übertrieben wenn jetzt
leute lieber zehn minuten videos alle
zwei minuten lange werbung schalten ich
mache das auch stadt dass alle fünf
minuten was kommen damit ihr halt nicht
nur noch werbung guckt auf meinem kanal
allerdings schaltet dieser youtuber 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 mal werbung in einem
zehn minuten video das heißt du guckst
quasi von der zeit her gesehen mehr
werbung als wirklich dieses video und da
bin ich auf dem handel das heißt wenn
das ging der sieg der mich kennt denkt
wahrscheinlich dass ich da irgendwie mit
drin stecke aber ich schaue mir das
video mal weiter an
ist das dein ernst sein komplettes video
besteht daraus ein chat verlauf zu
filmen und irgendwelche wieder runter zu
packen an denen ich will die rechte hat
zwei millionen views nach 48 stunden
willst du mich verarschen youtube oder
youtube als rebell wie dieser typ heißt
überhaupt kein held gegen die person
dahinter steht aber es also zu beginn
hat mich echt nicht abgefragt dass ich
darauf und habe war ich dachte da kommt
ein cooles video und das hat einfach in
typen gesucht der vielleicht ein
bisschen verdutzt guckt oder so aber
dieses video was ihr gebracht hast eine
komplette scheiße also du schaltest fall
werbung bei dem zehn minuten video wohl
nur ein chat verlauf films und das mit
musik an den du nicht die rechte heisst
backes und übels landtitel damit so
feuer flamme wachst mich auf st
aber okay du lernst dafür hat auch schon
harddisks und paten negative kritik in
den kommentaren aber hey was soll das
ich hab euch den video legen weil die
beschreibung gepackt ich will überhaupt
nicht dazu aufrufen dieses video zu
helfen oder so bitte macht es nicht aber
ihr könnt die person ja vielleicht mal
darauf hinweisen in den kommentaren
vielleicht auf englisch oder wenn ihr
spanisch könnte vielleicht auf spanisch
dass das nicht eher auf dem kamel ist
sondern ich und ich könnte theoretisch
sein komplettes video runter nehmen
lassen ich will allerdings lassen
sondern ich will ihm diese chance geben
dass er selber machen kannst du darfst
quasi sein video auch wenn es noch so
scheiße ist irgendwie noch online bleibt
weil ich bin jetzt auch kein unmensch
oder so aber ich meine wenn vom content
feiert alles machen aber links in der
beschreibung
kommen wir zur nächsten sache für die
ich wirklich auch nur ganz kurz reden
wollte ich bin der oldtimer 15 minuten
eigentlich hast dich ja diese videoton
videos und ihr mögt es ja auch nicht so
gern dass ich so von lange lava es ist
gerade halb fünf und ich kommen quasi
gerade aus der uni die uni hat um 2 uhr
angefangen und ich wollte halt hier so
um 10 42 loslaufen zu uni damit passend
da bin und als ob einmal an der tür
geklingelt und ich dachte erst ok wer
könnte sein so paketdienst bisschen spät
so eigentlich gar nichts bestellt die
kumpels wollten jetzt auch nicht
vorbeikommen wer natur gegangen ist
aufgemacht hat schon viele leute von rtl
einen kameramann ein tonmann
eine frau die mir das alles erklärt also
bisschen regie geführt hat und eine
gesundheits ernährungswissenschaftlerin
denkt man sich natürlich einfach solche
jetzt brauchen ist ja schon schlimm
genug dass da rtl vor der tür steht
vielleicht habe ich ja einige von euch
mitbekommen aber während der video days
habe ich ja auch seinen beitrag für rtl
explosiv gedreht die quasi gezeigt haben
wie es für youtube bei dem video days
ist beitrag wurde nie ausgestrahlt
setzer zwei stunden mit denen machen in
diesem band räumt denken sich einfach
mehr zeigen wir nicht löschen war alles
auf jeden fall korrekt rtl ich mag euch
nicht das hat jetzt aber gar nichts mit
dieser sache hier zu tun sondern die
stadt wirklich vor meiner tür und ich
hab dann so gefragt was wollt ihr von
mir ich dachte wirklich erst hätte
irgendein interview-termin verpennt oder
so dass mir mein manager englisch
geschrieben hat sich auch luca
deutschland ein interview nicht
vergessen einzutragen oder so aber
eigentlich will ich da echt immer
strukturiert was termine und sowas
angeht und habe dann halt die leute
gefragt die orad mir irgendein termine
und die westler gar nicht wer ich war
also die wussten nicht dass ich jetzt
eben die youtube mache oder so und haben
wir halt nur so gesagt dass sie für
irgendeine sendung ich weiß nicht mehr
welche das war vielleicht bauer sucht
frau rinscheid ich zeige euch einfach
mal wie die ganze situation ab gelaufen
ist könnte das denn sein
kein besucher erwartet eigentlich wegen
regen stoppen die wollten den mein
kühlschrank schauen
ich möchte stellt euch das vorstellten
nichts ahnen zu hause auf der couch auf
einmal klingelt und fährt ihn bei euch
und fragen an den kühlschrank kaufen ich
habe dann gesagt dass ich zur uni muss
und da halt auch ehrlich gesagt keine
bottrop hat und ich sind wirklich so und
die schnauze gesagt habe überhaupt
nichts gegen rtl an sich aber die
erfahrung die ich bisher mit diesem
sender gemacht habe bei kooperationen
oder tv sendungen war einfach unter
aller sau jedenfalls habe ich den dann
abgesagt die sind dann halt abgecheckt
und
heute hat einfach noch kurz berichten
weil ich dachte okay wenn ich jetzt die
ganze über den spanischen youtube trend
der rede was ich heute erfahren habe und
oder dieser rtl packte die mir heute
passiert ist kann ich jetzt halt auch
noch mit reinbringen solar video das war
es jetzt auch mit dem video meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat
last auf jeden fall mal leichter
schreibt man die kommentare was ihr von
dem spanischen video haltet und was ihr
den rtl leuten sagen würde kurzen
vorlauf ich bin ab morgen freitag bis
sonntag in amsterdam weil ich darauf
zwei partys bin und bin damit kollegen
halt und wir feiern da halt so ein
bisschen und ich war halt auch noch nie
so wirklich in amsterdam unterwegs
videos sind vorproduziert aber ich
wollte einfach mal fragen ob ihren blog
volt in der zeit also wenn ihr wollt
dass ich diese zeit locker ist ein
bisschen so typisch bescheuert witzig
wie luca mäßig dann schreibt malblock
unten in die kommentare dann weißt du
das ja und dann sehen wir uns in den
nächsten video wieder ausgeräumt main
kanal abonnieren
dann könnt ihr da drauf klicken bei da
ist ja mein kanal abonnieren hier findet
ihr auch irgendein video eingeblendet
könnt ihr auch abdecken bisher